weniger kontakte weniger
bewegungsfreiheit vier weitere
bundesländer verschärfen ihre chor ohne
regeln und schaffen erneut einen
flickenteppich historischer schneefall
und historische kälte sturmtief
philomena lässt spanien im schnee
versinken und fordert mehrere todesopfer
grandioser start grandioser sieg
francesco friedrich wird auch im
viererbob europameister und ist jetzt
der erfolgreichste bobpilot der weltcup
geschichte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den sonntags nachrichten den sport
gibt's jeder von norbert lehmann
einander von mir
die anhaltend hohen corona zahlen lassen
bund und ländern offenbar keine wahl
und so werden die bis heute geltenden
einschränkungen nicht nur bis ende des
monats verlängert sondern auch
verschärft und nach und nach umgesetzt
in hamburg und brandenburg gelten sie
schon heute ziehen in berlin
niedersachsen thüringen und mecklenburg
vorpommern nach
dort dürfen sich nur noch ein haushalt
plus eine weitere person treffen
für kinder gibt es ausnahmen die 15
kilometer regeln für corona hot spots
wird in den ländern unterschiedlich
umgesetzt in brandenburg gilt sie nur
für ausflüge thüringen belässt es bei
einer empfehlung volker dutschek und
florian coaching winterspaß trotz corona
beschränkung im knüll fällt in der
region oberhof 1000 große und kleine
freizeitsportler den rodelhang hinunter
seit heute gilt hier in thüringen die
neuerung wer in einem landkreis mit mehr
als 200 neuinfektionen in einer woche
pro 100000 einwohner lebt darf sich nur
noch 15 kilometer von zu hause weg
bewegen
die vorschrift ist allerdings nur eine
empfehlung das obwohl die sieben tage
incidents bei 409,1 in dem landkreis
liegt damit tatsächlich jetzt auch in
den behörden das problem dass teilweise
personalausfälle aufgrund von
erkrankungen oder auch ganz und gar
quarantine zeigen eben da sind so dass
ich echt nicht weiß wie das die behörden
umsetzen sollten keine androhung von
strafen thüringens verwaltung hoffen auf
die einsicht der bürger zumindest am
ersten tag der verschärfung sind die
pisten und hängen nicht überlaufen
abstand halten und hygiene vorschriften
gelten als schutz in der korona krise
und das impfen
thüringen liegt bei den impfungen pro
1000 einwohner bei 4,9 schlusslicht ist
sachsen mit 4,4 dann baden württemberg
die liste führt mecklenburg vorpommern
mit 15,6 vertreter der kommunen
appellieren beim impfen noch stärker auf
ältere mitmenschen zuzugehen
ganz schwierig ist das thema ambulanz
menschen zu erreichen die einsame
alleine in ihren wohnungen sitzen müssen
wir ganz ganz schnell zu zu
möglichkeiten kommen sie auch abzuholen
und in die impfzentren dann zu fahren
ich glaube das ist das gebot der stunde
steht für stört die schwächsten zu
erreichen bundesweit haben inzwischen
zahlreiche impfzentren ihre arbeit
aufgenommen
hochbetrieb wird hier allerdings erst in
wochen herrschen
der blick auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen die sind am wochenende meist
niedriger da nicht alle gesundheitsämter
ihre daten an das robert-koch-institut
übermitteln
so registrierte das lka knapp 17.000
neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden
außerdem 465 neue todesfälle in
verbindung mit coop 19
das superwahljahr wird eine
herausforderung für alle parteien auch
die linke bereitet sich vor und sieht
die chance auf mehrheiten links von der
union
nur so sei ein ökologischer und sozialer
kurswechsel möglich sagt parteichefin
kipping vom jahresauftakt der linken
andreas schubert die linke und ihr
leitmotiv fürs kommende jahr macht das
land sozial so steht es im
strategiepapier der parteispitze darin
das klare bekenntnis sich als die linke
kraft in deutschland für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit einzusetzen auch und
gerade in zeiten der pandemie
insofern geht es auch darum ein
machtpolitisches fenster links der union
zu öffnen damit werden die notwendigen
kurswechsel einleiten können
denn wer das demokratische gemeinwesen
jetzt aus der krise führen will braucht
den mut zu 9
nicht nur neues auch eine alte forderung
der linkspartei ist niedergeschrieben
die vermögensabgabe für reiche um damit
auch die finanziellen folgen von corona
abfedern zu können
die millionäre und milliardäre in dieser
gesellschaft sollen beim freibetrag von
einer million euro
5 prozent vermögensabgabe leisten die
wirtschaftspolitischen leitlinien sehen
außerdem einen ökologischen und
ökonomischen politikwechsel in
wirtschaft und gesellschaft vor gelingen
soll das unter anderem mit mehr geld für
pflegekräfte und der rückführung aller
privaten krankenhäuser in öffentliches
eigentum
unsere aufgabe ist es das soziale in
diesen sozial-ökologischen umbau staat
zu machen denn das ist das wo uns
kernkompetenz und auch zugesprochen
werden von den wählerinnen und bildern
und das sehe ich auch wirklich als
unsere aufgabe als linke am
strategiepapier haben sie noch mit
geschrieben in den wahlkampf werden sie
die linke aber nicht führen
beim parteitag ende februar tritt das
duo kipping riexinger als vorsitzende ab
der sturm aufs kapitol in washington hat
auch hierzulande folgen
so habe die berliner polizei ihre kräfte
am reichstagsgebäude bereits verstärkt
schrieb bundestagspräsident schäuble
laut bild am sonntag den abgeordneten in
den usa wollen die demokraten morgen ein
neues amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
präsident trump auf den weg bringen
auch mehrere republikanische
kongressabgeordnete unterstützen die
resolution nach dem gewaltsamen sturm
von trump anhängern auf das kapitol gab
es in mehreren städten proteste gegen
den noch amtierenden präsidenten wie
hier am times square in new york
auch in chicago forderten demonstranten
trump aus dem amt zu entfernen
sturmtief philomena sorgt in spanien an
diesem wochenende für die heftigsten
schneefälle seit 50 jahren mit am
stärksten betroffen ist die region rund
um madrid für viele einwohner ist dass
die seltene gelegenheit zum skilaufen
oder auch für schneeballschlachten
mitten in der hauptstadt aber es gibt
auch tote zu beklagen eine arendt
berichtet der schnee fiel unerbittlich
30 stunden lang in spaniens hauptstadt
manche einen madrilenen hat das
winterchaos eiskalt erwischt
momentan habe ich sehr kalte füße viele
haben stiefel an
ich müsste mir vielleicht auch mal
welche kaufen heute nacht wird es sehr
kalt werden und alles was jetzt schnee
ist wird dann zu eis das wird das größte
problem bis die bauplanung und so helfen
beim kampf gegen die weißen massen alle
mit mehr als 1500 menschen steckten am
wochenende auf den verschneiten straßen
der hauptstadt region fest das militär
ist im einsatz um wichtige zutaten etwa
zu den krankenhäusern freizuhalten der
schnee behindert die ohnehin schon
schleppend gestartete corona
impfkampagne
unsere sicherheitskräfte werden nun alle
ihre kapazitäten dafür auf dass trotz
der schneemassen die maßnahmen gegen die
korona pandemie und die impfungen in
allen regionen aufrechterhalten werden
können
auf historischen schneefall folgt nun
historische kälte der winter hat spanien
mit aller wucht erfasst nach dem
flugzeugabsturz in indonesien ist nun
der flugschreiber der abgestürzten
maschine im mehr geortet worden
einsatzkräfte entdeckten zudem trümmer
kleidungsstücke von passagieren und
leichenteile
die boeing 737 500 einer indonesischen
airline mit 62 menschen an bord war
gestern kurz nach dem start in jakarta
vom radar verschwunden
ja und nun zum wintersport und zu
norbert und da feiert ein deutscher
bobfahrer sensationelle erfolg absolut
francesco friedrich
der hat in winterberg erstmals in seiner
karriere auch im viererbob dem em-titel
geholt gleichzeitig seien 46 der weltcup
sieg ja und damit ist er der
erfolgreichste bobpilot in der
weltcup-geschichte mehr als der rekord
freut friedrich und seine männer wie gut
ihr erster viererbob einsatz in diesem
winter geklappt hat ein sieg in
winterberg wie gestern im zweierbob den
francesco friedrich seit jahren nahezu
unangefochten dominiert 46 weltcupsiege
jetzt damit löst der 30 jährige an der
spitze dieser statistik andré lange ab
für friedrich eine nebensache
wichtig war es dass der fahrer seine
bewerbungsfoto gemacht hat wir sind
glücklich dass es so gut gelaufen ist
heute em-zweiter wird österreich vor
russland
im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga verliert augsburg gegen
stuttgart mit 1 zu 4 die schwaben jetzt
zehnter augsburg elfter gestern starke
polen heute starke norweger beim
skispringen den titisee neustadt halberg
nagano lutz gewinnt mit 140 und 138
metern seinen sechsten weltcup sieg in
dieser saison zweiter sein landsmann
daniel andere tande bester deutscher
markus eisenbichler er verpasst wie
schon gestern knapp das podest und wird
wieder vierter vor einer woche der
sensationssieg in zagreb heute macht
linus strasser mit seinen zweiten platz
beim weltcup in adelboden klar der
deutsche zählt zu den besten im slalom
nach platz zwölf im ersten durchgang -
straße auch in adelboden mit einem
starken zweiten lauf und im ziel mit der
zwischenzeitlichen führung
aber das wusste aus den ersten dass sich
das auch im zweiten nicht gut anziehen
wird und ich habe es wirklich bis unten
probiert durchzuziehen was mich ganz gut
gelungen ist so gut dass nur der
österreicher marco schwarz mit einer
schnelleren zeit ins ziel kommt dritter
wird der brite dave reid
das war schon gedanken arbeiten und wir
haben noch den blick aufs wetter morgen
scheint die sonne im süden wenn sich der
nebel lichtet im norden dichte wolken
und etwas regen
minus 5 bis plus sechs grad das war es
von uns danke dass sie dabei waren
mehr gibts von marietta slomka im heute
journal um drei viertel ziehen
wir wünschen noch einen schönen
sonntagabend und sehen uns hoffentlich
morgen wieder um 19 uhr
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit berlin
direkt und sharon terlep energy